[Music]
what I am faze clan I have this [ __ ]
tattooed on my [ __ ] body this is my
life I put so much time and effort and
energy into this thing dominating New
York in 2017 this will live on past me
this is my legacy
[Applause]
[Music]
what I really can't believe what I'm at
in life right now I'm so excited to move
to California I'm over the snow I came
out here by myself with the hope and the
dream of being one of the biggest people
on the internet I can honestly say
imagine how dumb I feel right now
to my fans to all of fazes fans I love
you so much baby peace love it basement
[Applause]
riki Bankston doesn't always faze banks
in fact when banks started his career
phase or his competition like a lot of
gamers who played first person shooters
back in 2012 banks was a trickshot er
and a damn good one at that early on in
his YouTube career banks or banks has
Bank was the leader of soar a Call of
Duty trickshotting and sniping clan that
was much smaller but in a similar vein
to faze at the time phase with the big
kids on the block and had exploded in
popularity due to their viral ilk am
series whereas soar or a smaller
trickshotting clan looking to make a
name for themselves honestly I'm a firm
believer in if you don't do something
different you're not gonna succeed
nobody wants to subscribe to a channel
that exactly like another channel you
know you had phased air tgn supra all
these teams that are bigger than us you
had you know jump in and do something
different
in the early 2010's gaming on YouTube
wasn't always the hollywood-esque
spectacle it is now back then uploads
were short and raw there weren't always
fisheye lenses or luxurious backdrops
just fast 40-second black ops 2 360
noscopes that was the order of things
online if you wanted respect it was
earned through trickshotting
and banks garnered plenty of respect
as sore grew banks began to insert a
little bit more personality into his
channel next question
Lil Wayne XPO have you ever been in
trouble with the law if so what for I
don't know why said law but I'll answer
this it's probably took me a while to
answer but I'm just gonna answer
thoroughly he had that sort of low
budget let me tell you about my life
kind of charm that you'll find a lot of
if you venture into the archives of
YouTube's biggest stars it wasn't always
pretty but it was passionate and
authentic with his popularity on the
rise one of the most influential
partnerships in the history of gaming
took place in March 2013 as you can tell
from the title this video or you know if
you've been paying attention of my
twitter youtube past few days I joined
phase which is [ __ ] sweet the uniting
of banks and phase was a jumping-off
point for the organisation's future he
and temper another early phase member
lived 20 minutes from each other in
Massachusetts and very quickly made the
decision to move in together to continue
to allow phase to grow in addition to
producing his usual content banks began
to splice in general phase content as
well he saw an opportunity to build the
phase name into something larger than
Call of Duty something with a real
identity it was also with the addition
of banks that phase clam kicked off a
popular phase 5 YouTube show a first
step into personality based content on
their main channel that proved to be
extremely popular we tried our best to
make it you know a complete event we
didn't want to do a regular recruitment
challenge we wanted to be different and
I really can we achieve that which was
the overall goal well the overall goal
was to get 5 amazing players we did that
and you know a close second is for you
guys to enjoy
um the content and I really think you
guys did even early on in its
development there was an urge from banks
and company that faze clan should be
known as much as a lifestyle product as
for the gaming footage they put on the
screen they say there's no such thing as
a dumb question boy is this a dumb
[ __ ] question what's so good about
you boy what's so good about you what
isn't so good about Foley it's [ __ ]
delicious Joey's the best I live for joy
when he was a trickshot her without a
camera it was no mistaking the
personality that banks brought to his
content that's kind of a personal
question Balki what the [ __ ] I'll answer
it I lost my virginity eighth grade
summer in a way that's become normalized
on YouTube over the past five years
banks was willing to bear it all very
early on her friend was down to do some
weird [ __ ] with me and my girlfriend and
I was obviously a hundred percent down
for and I was excited for it I was
ecstatic this is something that every
guy wants to do banks wanted you to know
who he was to him this is all about
being real I really can't believe what
I'm at in life right now I can't believe
where I was at two years ago and I think
about every day I think about you guys
every day I [ __ ] love you guys and I
just want nothing more than just to make
you guys laugh and I want to give you
guys a place to have fun it was with
banks that ill cams was all of a sudden
paired with lifestyle content it was a
way of letting fans see what went on
behind closed doors in a way that was
unconventional at the time yeah this is
I setup I got one martyr here I honestly
don't on the specs for it I know the
specs for this one this one will be with
my my computer specs I got the two
monitors I'm gonna get another one when
I move into the house they never forgot
their roots in montages and Cod content
but they quickly paired it with content
that allowed its members to build their
online audience with each passing week
banks and faze clan felt like your
YouTube friends your homies that you got
to know a little better with each upload
during phases early years of development
in late 2012 and into 2013 the
organization took the dive into FPS
eSports one of their biggest rivals in
the trickshotting game was optic gaming
optic were one of the first content
creation orgs to leap into the
competitive world
in early 2013 right around the time
banks joined on and things were starting
to gather momentum phase fielded their
first Call of Duty eSports roster it was
with that Cod team that phase Glenn
splintered even further they added an
eSports presence to their channel and
banks and temper were the faces behind
all of it as phase started to grow into
the org that we know today banks took a
major step back from the content
creation throughout 2014 after all
somebody had to handle the business side
of things but that was all about to
change with phases growth and more
people involved behind the scenes with
faze clan than ever
banks took a new direction with his
content in 2015 he left the
trickshotting and gameplay to other
members of the faze clan brand and
dedicated his channel completely to his
personality my single favorite thing in
life my favorite kinds of experiences or
personal experiences relationships human
interaction I love people I [ __ ] love
people that's why I started YouTube in
the first list that's why I like to
travel and go a place like the Uni see
New York this is this is why this is
what I live my life for to meet new
people to put it simply he became a
vlogger he decided to turn [ __ ] around
on the Internet he did his product
obviously you guys are probably
wondering how the [ __ ] I broke this and
I debated on whether or not I should
tell you guys the truth I got into a
fight and I'm not a punk I'm not I'm not
I'll look for trouble I was at my house
and I was defending myself and that's
really all I have to say about it but
this new approach didn't last long in
2016 banks quickly disappeared from
YouTube again this time for a much more
serious reason anyone familiar with him
knows that banks has always been an
expressive person someone who's never
afraid to speak his mind get emotional
or let himself go wild
and that larger-than-life personality
was only amplified by the increasingly
massive horse that phase was becoming
both their influence in the gaming space
and in content creation even as faze
clan continued to grow and the eSports
side of the operation was trying to
branch into counter-strike banks hit
rock bottom about a year and a half ago
a little bit further than that almost
two years ago I started to overthink
things I wasn't sleeping a lot I was
running really fast and at this time I
was the overall leader of phase I
thought I could never go down I thought
I could never I basically didn't think
anybody could tell me [ __ ] I handled
things super poorly during this time
between that and the culmination of just
my friend and mine being so lost I I hit
rock bottom I went from here all the way
down there and it was the worst part of
my whole life I went crazy in February
of 2016 and I lost my friend in mind and
I pushed out these guys away long story
short I got myself submitted to his
mental hospital but he bounced back he
got back to YouTube and took things to
the next level I just [ __ ] around and
accidentally got the best tattoo I have
so there's that C phase was still
surging as a brand and they wanted to
see that continue and the way they did
that was to move the entire operation to
Los Angeles California after some time
banks joined the rest of them on the
coast but not in the phase house at the
point that banks moved to LA in 2017 he
was still a part owner in phase and
still worked on a lot of the front
facing parts of the product highway I
don't know why people think for some
reason I'm not stone-faced I'm a part
owner in the team I'm still in phase
stop asking that please but the company
was massive and there was no need for
banks or any of the og phase guys to be
involved in the business side of things
so when faze went to LA and temper rain
and adapt and company moved in together
banks went with them but live down the
street to a different house with
different roommates to start a new
project this time not about gaming meets
lifestyle this
it was a full-on entertainment brand
cloak game 10 racks for you guys know
what's up this is for real no trolling
first we're gonna find the [ __ ] which
rights just commit to me somehow to sit
in an elevator with him but oh thank you
sir 24-hour challenge at the crib so we
might as well as Travis Banks return to
YouTube in a massive way and
collaborated with some of Los Angeles's
most beloved and controversial YouTube
stars to create content that was about
living he was gonna make video sell
clothes and make it big and flashy yo
car did stop by the cousin birthday
today so are you ready to help me in
this [ __ ] this new era of his content
was a little less about phase and a lot
more about banks but he never forgot his
roots his channel exploded
over the course of 2017 banks his
channel jumped from just over a million
subscribers to more than four million I
came out here by myself with the hope
and the dream of being one of the
biggest people on the internet and doing
all these crazy things and seeing out
all my ideas and making all my dreams
come true and I can honestly say I did
it I did it he become the kind of
celebrity that fans would tune into just
to see what they were doing what they
were wearing and who they were hanging
out with he got rich online with just a
console a capture card and a dream and
it was something that everyone wanted to
watch
since the transition from scuff
controllers in search-and-destroy maps
to easy sneakers and Gucci bags banks
has found himself in spats with some of
the internet's most talked about
celebrities notably he was caught smack
dab in the middle of the infamous
breakup between jig Paul and vlogger
Alyssa violet who moved into the clout
house and began dating banks immediately
after their split just a touch on enough
that you guys on me and Alyssa since her
birthday she's officially my girlfriend
now weird it's like cringy to say that I
don't know it's it doesn't need to be
that complicated I don't really care for
like titles or whatever I really care
about but of course there was no
shortage of clickable content that came
after to this day some of the most
popular videos to come out of the entire
Club gang project are the rap music
video diss tracks from pinning rice gum
and alyssa against Jake from there he
was also accused of and then allegedly
framed for assaulting one of Jake Paul's
assistants at an LA nightclub while this
beep was still festering
evil brutal monster who did this [ __ ] on
purpose all clear when I was leaving he
sort of clothesline to me and put their
arm out in front of me and tried to like
hold me you like photos are not like
like this and I was looking up at him
and our faces were really close as you
guys can see the d-ends from Nick and
what she's saying on camera in front of
millions of people are two totally
different things and that's a series
you've logged all of this yeah what's
going on it's it's Fox News yeah I was
pretty upset yeah so I'm actually I'm
actually in the process of pursuing this
legally right now and my lawyers and my
team have advised me not to speak with
you guys from dramatic confessionals to
pranks and parties banks was in the
belly of the internet beast and he knew
how to turn it into content since the
call of duty' heyday banks has become
increasingly distant from the front
lines of the gaming space
he had always envisioned phase as the
intersection between life style and
gaming and that succeeded but gaming
wasn't as big a part of his life as it
once was
until for tonight everybody misses the
old fans you know that old style just
heavy gaming cool clips cool trick shots
and just like montages great music
behind the keyword we're so excited me
exactly every single day we have the
best team in the world don't at me
monsters this game is brand new man it's
at its infancy for tonight we're gonna
do what we did and revolutionize it and
change it whether you like it or not
we're gonna do it and we're gonna make
everybody know about it he was swept up
in the hype just like everybody else
and naturally phase in fortnight were a
perfect fit and banks was an integral
part of bringing on board one of the
biggest names the gaming world has seen
in a long time yeah rice can be worked
out
look at me there is a kind of site but
your quota anyone mine yeah you guys
gave him a call I don't know he's doing
it in unfortunately Teague was just so
utterly and completely faze clan he
understood that content came first but
when it came time to perform on stage he
had ice in his veins and he and banks
were boys for sure whatever gotta show
the homies come along to support the
homies everybody's did that what the am
i doing with my life
official boys we're brothers for life
blood brothers we use the same needle
and everything somehow with the help of
fortnight the monumental force that the
phase brand had become was only getting
bigger alongside cloak sea basses
fortnight duo were winning everything
streaming to tens of thousands at a time
and uploading 10 million view YouTube
videos but most importantly look cool
doing it what is wrong with you doing my
bro - yo bro let's get some food let's
get some drinks drinks now a shout with
every future fortnight signing the brand
tightened its grip on the gaming world
but then controversy struck show the
[ __ ] contract phase release the
[ __ ] contract everybody hashtag
release the [ __ ] contract news broke
that T foo was suing faze clan and banks
was crushed first off I just want to say
I don't agree with what him and his team
have done I think it's complete and
utter most of it is a complete lie
exaggerated and its tactical which you
don't use tactics and legal strategy
against friends cuz I thought before
anything else before the business [ __ ]
before anything like that before
egos before I've used before all that
honestly I thought we were friends
teef who I called you my family
have this kid's name tattooed on my
[ __ ] leg like imagine how dumb I feel
right now the new scent that gaming
world reeling in just weeks later the t
fus Fame duo partner cloak seat had also
left phase yeah we haven't been in
agreement with me the evening for the
past six months because they've been
trying to leave for the past six months
before the whole t food thing came out
now in many ways this incident
epitomizes Banks's career but not in a
bad way everyone [ __ ] thinks they
want to be a CEO
nobody wants an austere it's the worst
job of all time every [ __ ] thing that
happens that's wrong
you're the statement yeah it's you and
you need to [ __ ] move [ __ ] around and
makes it happen and make it better
that's you everything ties back to you I
do that when it comes to the branch it
like when something like the t4 things
happen thing happens it's my
responsibility to [ __ ] to figure out
how we're gonna [ __ ] how we're gonna
sort through that yeah he lashed out he
was emotional and reactionary when he
saw the teeth who news he was blindsided
faster code is what I used to say about
t food he was another one who helped you
very very early on because he saw what I
saw on you never pay that forward never
[ __ ] cash that check ever return the
favor on that now now it's all about
girls who met you after the fact and
people who met you after the fact in
lawyers who you [ __ ] pay you've never
paid me a dime in your [ __ ] life and
I've done more for you than any of these
people ever haven't ever could but
that's Bay's banks the heart on his
sleeve screaming to the microphone kind
of guy this situation specifically
specifically with T foo really he fires
me up because I'm I've been so
emotionally invested in this kid from
the day that I met him but it wasn't out
of greed it's not bank's writing
contracts and making backroom deals he's
the one who found t fus streaming to a
hundred viewers and helped to turn him
into a superstar
I contacted Club and I told him listen
cloaked or the captain of the team I
would never normally suggest for you to
play with someone or if you'd a team
with somebody or the captain I trust
your judgment
I trust you a call I want you to have
the roster that you want but with that
being said please play with my homey T
foo who's really [ __ ] good
just scrim with him give him a chance
and clothes response to that was
along the lines oh I know who he is
we're not interested in Turner knows how
to get kills but he's not good at
building we have this person this person
this person this person in mind he don't
want to play with TV again I pushed him
yo just play with him he's what faze
clan is and that's become massive he's
trying to keep up with what he's created
something so much bigger than a kid from
Boston could have dreamed I'm sure I'm
gonna have a [ __ ] ton of hate on this
video I mean you're massive I feel like
I've created a monster in some way but
if that's the price I have to pay then
so be have to tell the truth and I have
to get my side of the story out there
there's gonna be hiccups along the way
friends lost and messy pathless but if
there's anything that's clear watching
all of this news unfold it's that banks
isn't going anywhere from the moment he
and Temper moved in together BAE's
changed forever they fuse gaming and
personality in a way that the world had
never seen it was about style and skill
all at the same time and you still see
that lasting Banks effect on the brand
today
because of banks this is more than just
pixels on a monitor because of banks
it's a lifestyle thanks for watching if
you want more content like this hit the
sub button and bring that notification
of Bell for unique bite-sized videos you
won't find anywhere else hit up our
Instagram Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]